- So I have a distinct
challenge for you.
- Okay.
- Let's see if you can it.
- I can.
- I've got one minute.
(audience laughter)
One minute left, in one minute
can you tell all these people
what's on the one nugget you
want to leave them with that
they should go back
to their offices?
One minute.
You're gonna die.
(audience laughter)
I don't know if you've heard.
And I'm being dead serious.
There's so much opportunity.
The people in this room can do
so much if they allow themselves
to play a game based on
them being self-aware about
themselves and what they want
their legacy and skill
sets to deploy against.
We are in a rat trap.
We are in a circle.
We're all saying the same thing.
Anytime, I need new business
to grow, I go play your game.
It's that easy.
I reverse engineer
the human being that's
going to make the decision.
I let her or him dictate the
creative and we go on our merry
way and I want to
shoot myself in the face. Right?
And then I start beating them
up and saying I sold you,
now we're doing
none of that. Right?
Legacy, opportunity.
Those things.
This is an amazing time to
be in this industry if you're
on the offense and it's
the worst time to be in this
industry if you're
on the defense and
95% of you are on the defense.
And if I've got one of you to
switch from that shit side to
offense today then I feel
really good about myself.
(light music)